mais mais oui oui ce sont des 30 mais il
faut que j'avais mais mais oui ce sont
les trente mille fois que j'avais mais
au sort mais comment je vais faire
tu te rends compte je les ai perdus je
les ai perdus mais c'est pas à moi cet
argent c'est pas à moi c'est à mon
patron je demande la porte est tout à
l'heure quand j'ai vu que j'étais perdue
va me tuer mais comme c'est pas possible
mais je te parle girolles vous fait pas
de mauvais sang va perdre d'argent n'est
pas mortelle
trente mille francs de perdu dix de
retrouvés même jeter si c'était un mois
encore demi mal de commande minimale
mâles entiers ouais je trouve pourquoi
j'aurais perdu trente mille francs mois
d'un coup comme ça non ça va pas non 100
francs par 100 francs je dis pas à la
rigueur c'est comme si c'était des
petits traite ses proches des favelas
mais oui soul r b oui le tiers
provisionnel en suis là je n'ai pas
perdu ma son année en raison de dire
allez bon sens vont avec les mauvais qui
reste mais je les avais l'air et je les
avais la wii sont les avait dévoilé ses
retranchements
heureusement d y retrouver heureusement
d'ici sa fin s'ils les avaient pas
retrouvé que les aurait perdus
je vais quand je réfléchissais avait
perdu comment j'aurais fait comment
j'aurais fait mais il aurait fallu que
j'emprunte à un sauveur bas et m'aurait
pas prêter sauveur il m'aurait pas
prêter il m'aurait pas prêter ce pourri
et après tout le bien que j ai fait j'ai
mangé chez lui pendant un an et tous à
pouilly
mais sa carrière va qu'est ce que je
rencontrais alors demandé qu'est ce que
je regrette sa fin il a pas sauvés
sauveur avec moi va se faire mais à qui
j'aurais demandé alors j'aurais demandé
à bastien alors elle m'aurait pas prêter
bastien il aurait su que sauveur m a
refusé mon résidents se pourim aurait
refusé à moi et après tout le bien que j
ai fais tu sais pas quand je mangeais
pas chez sauveur je manger chez lui il
est mince affaire mais je leur dirai je
leur dirai je leur dirais vous êtes
moins un sport et sauveur deux
pourraient ensemble qui s'assemblent pas
pour aller dans le même sac à l'aller
c'est pas la peine je sais vous soit
mesdames et maintenant je sais où ils
sont c'est bien simple je n'ai pas un
bon mais alors vendre à qui j'aurais
demandé alors à qui j'aurais demandé
j'aurais demandé à un horaire je connais
à peine beaucoup de courage hayward à
l'issue de quatre qui me les aurait
prêté lambert peut-être qu'ils maison il
me connaît pas alors il les aurait prêté
tu te rends compte des norbert qui
prenaient pas une vraie prête et c2
pourri de sauveur et bastian refait mais
c'est pas vrai mais cannes c'est un
article norbert mais c'est une pâte
c'est au miel ce type là il faut le
garder lui faut le garder mais je leur
je leur dirais vous n'avez pas honte
un étrange il me prêtez vous ne prêtez
pas vous êtes mes frères vous soit
disant l'amitié les frères haddad à
l'éolien devrait pas au là là mais quel
brave type ce norbert qu'une patte il
faut le garder lui a heureusement qu' à
norbert on a mais si ça se trouve même
pas il aurait voulu que du rand
comme je le connais il m'aurait dit non
non c'est pas la peine c'est pas la
peine pour toi de moi mais tu es norbert
voilà c'est ton argent juste les rangs
c'est normal en fait mais non à 30 mille
francs c'est pas la peine rose les
avaient alors parce qu'il se serait vexé
on aurait fait dès lors et en justice
des procédés rela bon ça va ça va jaur
écrasé le coup ça va mais quel brave
type the north bay 1 et tu te rends
compte qu elle brave type seuls ils me
prêtent 30 mille francs
il veut pas que je lui rende et bien
puisque c'est comme ça tout de suite je
vais aller lui demander ses trente mille
francs à norbert et on en parlera plus
voilà